what we're going to do in this video is
talk about factors and factor pairs now
when we talk about factors these are
really numbers that can be multiplied
together to make some number so for
example if I were to talk about factors
of 6 I could multiply 2 times 3 to get 6
and so we would say that 2 & 3 are
factors of 6 in fact we would also say
that 2 & 3 is a factor pair for 6
because when I multiply those 2 I can
get 6 now to think about all of the
different factor pairs for a number we
could think about it in terms of area
how can we make a rectangle with area 6
well you could do it if it's 2 units by
3 units so it could look something like
this I'll just hand draw it so let's say
it has so let's say our rectangle looks
like this so that's 2 rows and then 3
columns and let's say these all have
equal area it's hand drawn but you can
see that the area here would be 2 times
3 which would be equal to 6 square units
now what if what are other ways to get
to an area of 6 well you could have
something that is one row but then it
has six columns so maybe it looks
something like this
it looks like this so it's one row and
then you have 1 2 3 4 5 I want them all
to be roughly the same size so it's 1
times 6 would be also an area of 6 so
that would be another factor pair we
know that 2 times 3 is equal to 6 and we
know that 1 times 6 is equal to 6 and
these are actually the two factor pairs
4 6 and we can do it with larger numbers
we can think about what about all the
factor pairs for something like 16 pause
this video and see if you could think
about that well I'll set up a little
table here to think about that and so in
this column I'll put the first factor
and in this column I'll put the second
factor
and the way I like to do it is I start
at one and I keep working up up to the
number to try to figure out all of the
factors so let's start with 1 so 1 is
definitely divisible into 16 and as long
as you put a whole number here it's
going to be divisible by 1 and what I
have to multiply by 1 to get to 16 we'll
have to multiply it by 16 so that's a
factor pair right there 1 and 16 now
what about 2 does 2 go into 16 well sure
2 times 8 is 16 so that's another factor
pair 2 times 8 we found another factor
pair
now what about 3 does 3 go evenly into
16
well no 3 times 5 is 15 and 3 times 6 is
18 so 3 doesn't go into 16 so 3 would
not be a factor of 16 what about 4 well
4 times 4 is 16 so that's a factor pair
there 4 & 4 what about 5 well no you 5
times 2 is 10 5 times 3 is 15 times 5
times 4 is 20
5 does not go evenly into 16 same thing
for 6 6 times 2 is 12 6 times 3 is 18
does not go evenly into 16 what about 7
7 does not evenly go into 16 7 times 2
is 14 7 times 3 is 21
what about 8 well we already know that 8
goes evenly into 16 you might be tend to
say oh there's another factor pair of 8
times 2 but we already wrote that down
we just happened to say that 2 is the
first factor and 8 is the second factor
but you could say it the other way
around so we don't have to then go to 8
times 2 and once you've gone half way
you could be confident that you've
already found all the factor pairs
because then you could go to 9 9 doesn't
go into it 10 11 12 13 14 15 but then 16
of course is divisible by 16
but we've already written that here in
this factor pair so we have these three
factor pairs 1 in 16 2 & 8 & 4 & 4